he's just a nightmare pairing for
absolutely everybody no i have no idea
what dania's talking about if i'm being
totally honest i never thought i'd be
saying these words but i agree with levy
yeah this is crazy there are four
literal current world champions here
welcome to thechess.com global
championship bracket breakdown i am your
host international master danny wrench
alongside the one and only grand master
dania daniel naradiski and the biggest
chess youtuber on the planet
international master levi rosman also
known as gotham chess guys we are here
to break down chess.com's biggest event
ever the most exciting event we've ever
done uh levy starting with you how
pumped are you to see what happens in
the round of 64 and who makes it to
toronto i'm super excited danny we
haven't seen the chess event quite like
this one we normally invite all the
players and let them play but this time
only half the field is guaranteed to
spawn and the other half has had a
grueling way to get to the online round
of 64 and not to mention have a chance
to qualify for the final in toronto the
prize fund is huge the stakes are huge
the names are huge i'm pumped
like levy said 32 qualified 32 were
invited we're gonna get to the bracket
breakdowns here in just a minute but
dania over to you like levy said the
biggest prizes we've ever done more than
a million dollars in cash and then more
than a hundred thousand dollars if
anyone can get a perfect bracket donya
what are your chances you're giving our
community that someone gets a perfect
and gets a six-figure prize fund for
their efforts
well i don't want to be a debbie downer
danny but there's so many incredibly
strong players from every generation in
this field that i cannot imagine how one
can predict every result ag early but
that is exactly what makes this
tournament so incredibly epic the fact
that there are so many players out of
this field of 64 who have a serious shot
at winning it all
like danya said there's 64 of them every
one of them can win and in preparation
for recording this video for you fans i
can tell you our matchups and and who
we're picking is is all over the place
because anyone could take this home
we're gonna dive into all of that in
just a little bit it's more than a
million dollars in prizes it's a hundred
thousand dollars for you if you can be
perfect thousands of dollars in prizes
just participating and with that we are
going to jump into our bracket
breakdowns just around the corner
all right levy and delany it's time for
group a right there at the top we have
exciting matchups starting off with
hikaru nakamura versus rodrigo vasquez
david navarro versus michael adams
lanier dominguez perez versus maxime
shigayev and then you have laquan liam
versus eric hanson donya i'm going to
start with you of those first round
matchups which one do you have circled
as maybe the most exciting i'm going to
have to go with david navarra against
michael adams these two players are from
an older generation some of the younger
viewers might not have even heard of
them but michael adams was top 10 in the
world for something like two decades he
is not going to go gentle into that good
night and david navarra has an
absolutely fascinating chess style he's
super tactical and when he is on form he
can basically beat absolutely anybody
anybody so i'm keeping my eye squarely
on michael adams against david navarro
danny levy you sticking with that battle
or another one got your attention no i
have no idea what danya's talking about
if i'm being totally honest there is one
and only one incredibly interesting
matchup in this first round matchup of
all eight and that is la cuangliam
versus eric hanson and i will be gonna
say that likhwang liam has had an
amazing run of all of these online
events that he's played he has we've
seen him beat magnus he's had incredible
games and he's an amazing player but
he's playing eric hanson eric hanson is
a genius he is brilliant and he is the
dark horse in my opinion when you take a
look at this group if eric is on his a
game i think he's he's he's one of the
best rapid players that that we can see
in the world today
i'm going to agree with you levy i
actually think that that matchup maybe
has most of the world talking one
because eric hansen's fan base the chess
brawl and because we know what lakuang
liam is capable of of course hikara
nakamura being the top-seeded guy
probably most people's favorite to win
this group but back to you dania do you
see anyone but hikaru ultimately
emerging out of group a well i never
thought i'd be saying these words but i
agree with levy and i'm going to have to
go with lekwang lim he is a perpetually
underrated player his style isn't
necessarily as colorful and as ambitious
as the style of some of the other crowd
favorites but he is so incredibly
consistent he's an amazing blitz player
and he's got a years-long pedigree uh of
proven tournament victory so keep your
eye on the vietnamese number one
okay levy you going with the clone
william not just in the first round but
to win group a like dania
look for a second time in a row truly i
have no idea what my co-host daniel
naredinsky here is talking about folks
look i can't be contrarian just to be
contrarian if you look around the
tournament field and magnus carlson is
there that is who you put your money on
if you look around and he is not there
you look for hikar nakamura particularly
in speed chess we might have some
interesting matchups in this group
hikaru may have to go through some
serious tests like hans demon of course
his first round opponent as well and
maybe a rivalry with eric hanson or
lewang liam but folks i think picaro was
my favorite in group a
i'm going to have to go with levy on
this too sorry donya that we're picking
on you i think it's hard to pick against
hicaru as levi said it so well so i
won't i won't try to keep up with that
but i will circle one other person i
think ldp lanier dominguez perez also a
former world blitz champion don't sleep
on that guy even if he's not as young as
some of the players in the field he
might surprise some people before all is
said and done and that my friends has
been our take on group a
looking at group b we have some of the
biggest names in the game right at the
top we have yon shistop duda versus
mitrapa guha wang hao versus peter laco
next chakrillar mahmud yara faces off
versus vatislav kavaliev and then we
have veda gujarati versus alexis serrano
donya your thoughts i'm gonna have to go
with a little bit of a more predictable
choice i'm gonna say vidit against
alexis saron i mean both of these
players have proven themselves
especially alexis serrano he has turned
so many heads with his performances in
the rcc with his consistent performances
in title tuesdays and vidit gujarati
will he basically needs no introduction
both of these players
they are going to make a serious bid to
win the entire thing and i can't wait
for them to face off in the first round
that's not taking anything away from the
battles between wong how and peter laiko
and mohammed yara versus cavaliere i'll
say we definitely shouldn't turn our
head on daddy shock we know what he's
capable of but let me go back to you
levy and say of the eight players in
this group who do you think ultimately
emerges
oh this is so tough guys if i can make a
bailout please can i predict the final
matchup can i say mummy diara versus
duda and who's ever better on that day
if mamidyarov shows up and starts
throwing haymakers he's gonna break
through but dude is a fighter he's an
amazing defender and if shock is off his
game dude is moving on to the final in
toronto donya ugh this is tearing my
heart out danny but i picked yantra
stuff duda beforehand i'm not going to
go back on my choice he has
the most experience playing super
tournaments in the last couple of years
he's an incredible rapid player he's
going to come to the table with some
amazing opening preparation and i think
that's going to be the biggest
difference maker dude is opening
preparation taken from his candidate's
performance i think is going to push him
over the edge and get him to defeat the
likes of shakur our mom and drop
okay i might surprise both of you before
we leave this group behind by saying
that i think the first round matchup
might tell us who ultimately wins this
bracket i think whoever wins between
vitaguchrathy and alexis arana is
actually the favorite to win this
bracket i think sorana is often
overlooked way too often that guy is a
monster if any matchup gets to a blitz
tiebreaker and beyond i like him against
almost anybody else in the field not
taking anything away from obviously how
strong the players are so there you have
it everybody that was our breakdown of
group b
it's time to break down group c levy and
dania perhaps the biggest storyline in
this particular group is that we have
three americans in the field but only
one of them could make it out or none of
them will we're going to find out we
start with the match up at the top with
the top rated american wesley so taking
on dennis lazavick then we have the
second american ray robson taking on
vasily ivanchuk alexander grishik faces
off versus benjamin boak and then
jeffrey zhang versus alexander bortnick
donya throwing over to you first which
matchup has your head spinning danny i
am salivating at the prospect of
watching jeffrey jean take on alexander
bortnick now jeffrey he needs no
introduction and actually neither does
bortnick he might not be 2700 feet a he
might not even be 2600 feet eight but
nobody in the online chess sphere likes
facing alexander bortnick the guy is a
beast he went nine out of nine in a
title tuesday in 2016 and his
performance in online tournaments has
been nothing short of tremendous i think
jeffrey has his work cut out for him and
i'm keeping a very very close eye on
that matchup levy you're batting second
you agree with donya
well danny now i'm not i'm just gonna
look like the kid in the class who's
copying off the smart kid i was gonna
choose that matchup if you had come to
me first i just want the record to
reflect that but i do have a horse in
this race because i have played dennis
lazavich lazavik in title tuesday a
handful of times and he's made me look
like i was a thousand points lower than
i am so i'm cheering for him against
wesley so no disrespect whatsoever to
wesley i'm curious to see how dennis
does in the big leagues uh you both
picked a good matchup but in my in my
book you both struck out on this one to
me the most exciting matchup in the
first round has to be chucky vasiliya
vonck have we ever seen him playing in
an online chess tournament with these
types of stakes this guy one of the best
players in the world to never have had a
chance at the throne will he be the
chess.com global champion who knows i
think that matchup is the most exciting
but i'm going to throw it back to you
danya and say regardless of our first
round matchup debate who do you got
coming out of group c gosh i'm gonna go
with a very unconventional pick here now
yes i know wesley is wesley if i was
choosing it statistically i would go
with him but ray robson do not sleep on
ray he's almost 2700 feet a his opening
preparation is absolutely tremendous
and uh he's just a nightmare pairing for
absolutely everybody so if ray can get
through vaseline vancouver in the first
round i think that he's going to make a
serious bid to winning the entire group
and shocking the entire chess world
i am shocked by that but before i give
my thoughts gotta go to levy and get his
okay this is completely ridiculous i
mean i was honestly going to pick ray
robinson i had prepared this massive
monologue for the fact that ray robson
was a top junior my entire life i could
never be higher rated than him right and
he's been 2600 for a decade just an hour
there's a decade he's only gaining
rating anytime he takes chess seriously
but if we have to look around it's very
difficult to choose between wesley so
and ray robson in that second round
matchup but i think the experience the
advantage there goes to wesley let's not
forget he is a world champion i see
wesley emerging out of group c
no disrespect to ray i think of the
three americans he might be the least
likely but i'm gonna go with a different
person regardless i'm taking grishook
that guy our old uncle sasha is going to
get through group c and be dancing with
us in toronto canada
my friends that was our breakdown of
group c
it's time to break down group d for the
chess.com global championship levy and
dania one of the big questions everyone
is probably thinking about is will this
be the fabiano caruana redemption tour
maybe not a world champion maybe becomes
the firstchest.com global champion but
i'll let you give your thoughts on each
matchup as we jump into the bracket we
start things off with fabiano carwana
versus martine kravsev
then we have carill alexeyenko taking on
jose martinez
dimitri on jaken then faces off versus
aram hacobian
and then we have of vladimir ferrosayev
versus godakomsky levy you get to bat
leadoff in this case which matchup do
you have circled
oh without question it's vladimir
philisia vs godakomski of course we go
back to a previous generation godakomski
was just an absolute savage you saw him
paired in the same tournament you were
going to you shuddered a little bit an
absolute legend he still plays
constantly to this day he keeps up with
all the best names and fetishive needs
no introduction either he is constantly
winning all sorts of events a very very
tough opponent i'm looking forward to
that one donya your thoughts well
fabiana caruana danny you mentioned that
he's been struggling it's no secret that
he's been struggling mightily over the
past couple of tournaments and i think
he's going to bring his absolute a game
i'm very excited to see how he handles
his first round matchup against martin
kraftsev who is no pushover at all he
did a great job in the world blitz
championship is going to be a
fascinating fascinating first round
battle for fabiano i love the matchups
you guys chose i want to highlight that
jose martinez and demetria and jacon are
two guys who have made names for
themselves online over the last few
years and
both those guys and their matchups
should not be overlooked but we're going
to go back to you levy and say that
regardless of the first round matchup
that has us excited who do you think
wins this one
i think it's going to come down to
actually the bottom half of the bracket
that moves up so it's going to likely be
dimitri and draken moving on against
vladimir putin and i think whoever wins
that matchup will take it over whoever
emerges from the top half if i gotta
choose one i'm going on draken i like
the experience i like all of his results
thus far uh in the rapid championship
i'm going dimitri
jonya who do you got coming out of group
d see now i feel
like that kid in class who has to copy
uh to copy homework but i i can't change
my opinion vladimir fettis say i'm good
friends with him he's such a talented
player but on draken is on draken i mean
he the art his performance in the rcc is
performance on entitled tuesday the fact
that he's over 2700 feet a which a lot
of people seem to forget about he's got
the whole shebang the whole nine yards
i'm gonna have to agree with levy and go
with dimitri
i don't blame either of you from a
little bit of recency bias on draken
obviously a monster but i'm going to
accuse you of it because i'm going to
say when push comes to shove when the
stakes are at their highest the best
chess comes out and i think there's a
reason fabiano caruana is the third
highest rated player in history i think
his rapid chess has improved and i think
he joins us in toronto uh but either way
those are our thoughts and that my
friends was our take on group d it's
time for me levy and donya to break down
group e so many players so many matchups
here to dive into big question can
anybody stop nepo he's challenging for
the world title for a second time just
won the rapid chess championship let's
dive into the bracket and talk about
what these matchups will bring us we
start off right there at the top with
yon dupont mishi taking on muhammad
maradli then we have peter svidler
taking on alexi shiroff taymor rajab
will battle against hoey fawn and then
we have arjun ira geisse versus david
paravian who knows where to go uh what
to talk about here i'm going to start
with you dania which matchup do you have
circled well alexi shuroff should be a
familiar name to all he wrote a series
of best games collections called fire on
board and it's no coincidence that he
called it that because every time alexi
touches the chess pieces the chessboard
explodes i am choosing his match against
peter svidler who is very well known to
the chess world as an amazing player and
commentator sure of against svidler is
going to be one to watch levy did don
you steal your thunder or you got your
eyes on another matchup
no i'm looking at something completely
different danny i'm taking a look at
this matchup between arginary geisse and
david paravyon anytime david shows up to
play he might not be as of a house as
much of a household name i should say as
some of the other grand masters from
russia but this man comes to fight all
the time in argentina is one of the
fastest rising stars of india that is
the matchup that i'm looking at most
probably in this first round i'm going
to go a different direction here and
look at tamer vajava resurgent in his
career a little bit right now had a
pretty good showing there at the
candidates in madrid taking on one of
the only women players in the field but
one of the strongest players in the
field and of course the second highest
rated woman player of all time and hoey
fawn
i i don't know who i like in that match
up i think hoey fawn likes herself the
rapid the rapid format so that's one
that i'm definitely watching but i'm
going to go back to levy first and say
regardless of our first round matchups
do we see anyone but nepo coming out of
this one who do you got winning group e
no absolutely not yanipo nishi is going
to win this group and he is an
incredibly strong favorite for the
entire thing i think jan is probably the
second best chess player on the planet
right now maybe third we can have that
debate but my goodness i mean how do you
bet against jan in this group
i'll tell you how the time that we are
recording this arjun aragy's live rating
is 27-25
he won the tata steel challengers and he
literally just won the abu dhabi masters
a couple of days ago he is totally
unstoppable his level of play isn't just
27 20 he's playing at a 2800 level and
if he can carry that momentum through
argent eric guys he's going to be a
force to be reckoned with i think he's
going to give yonda palma a serious run
for his money
i agree with the two of you in in a
weird sense i'll say that i think our
final in this particular group is nepam
nishi versus hiragaisi i don't know
who's going to win i have to lean nepo
though and all right that was our take
on rookie
all right fellas it's time for us to
turn our attention to group f we've got
uh former world champions in this
bracket we have the potential for formal
world championship matchups that take
place in this group of eight players
we're gonna start things off at the top
of this bracket though as we look first
at anish giri versus women's world
champion juwon jun then we have vessel
into paulov taking on raunak sadwani
then you have vishwanathan anand versus
pavel pankroth and then reigning world
rapid champion notre beck abdusa turoff
versus boris gailfund guys
how do we circle a first round matchup
in this bracket levy you have the tough
task of leading us off
yeah this is crazy there are four
literal current world champions here and
there is one challenger to the world
championship throne this is an
unbelievable match i i don't know what
to choose you know what if if i'm going
first i'm obviously gonna take the juicy
one i gotta take the reigning defending
rapid champion of the world no dirbeck
abdusa tourev uzbek grand master vs
boris gelfan i'm pretty sure boris
gelfand has worked with all the
youngsters of the world he obviously was
a coach in india i don't know about how
much of an impact he's had on norther
back but that is what i'm looking at in
this first round matchup love that match
up donya your thoughts levy's stealing
my thunder again but vishy anand anytime
he plays in a tournament all eyes turn
toward fishy he has maintained his
strength uh through the years he has
kept putting in incredibly solid
performances i'm so excited to see how
far he can get in the global
championship and i'm going to be keeping
a close eye on his first round match
against a very strong grandmaster in his
own right pavel poncradov this is not a
bracket where we have to pretend to want
to talk about all four matchups i mean
chapala versus saudwani write another
former world champion and then anish
geary might be the top rated player but
he's taking on the reigning women's
world champion and juwon jun
wow everyone has their work cut out for
them i'm going to go back to you dania
that and ask you though who do you see
ultimately emerging out of group f well
i think levy said the key words reigning
world rapid champion this is a rapid
time control this
man this boy this monster he has been
building up confidence through the last
couple of tournaments put in yet another
amazing performance at the olympia i am
going with notre dame abdusutar of boris
gelfand his first round opponent is
going to be a force to be reckoned with
it ain't going to be an easy journey but
nerderbeck has been absolutely
unstoppable of late and i think he keeps
his momentum going with another
incredible performance
you stole donya's thunder earlier levy
did he just steal yours or you got
someone else winning group f
no i think know your back's first round
matchup is extremely interesting but i
think how can you root against uh the
tiger from madras i mean are are you
kidding me vishwanathan anand when this
man shows up to the uh to any playing
hall all the chess pieces start glowing
okay and when he takes on noderbeck and
if he does take on notre back i think i
think experience is going to triumph
over youth and i think vishwanathan
anand is moving on to the finals i'm
going to tell everyone they shouldn't
turn their back on the other young
player in the field in sadhuani he is so
comfortable playing online on chess.com
has been since he was i think maybe
three or four years old uh but i also
agreed that abdusatorov probably
probably the favorite given that he is
the reigning world rapid champion but
either way that was our look at group f
all right guys we are now gonna jump
into group g will this be vladimir
kromnic's unretirement party a uh world
not a world championship title but a
global championship title or someone
else coming out of this group let's take
a look at the bracket and preview each
matchup we start at the top with dingley
wren versus tuan min lee then we have
andre isapenko taking on bassem amin
vladimir kramnik as mentioned will be
taking on her aunt melchimian and then
we have nihal sauron versus ralph mohmet
donya you know i gotta ask you to choose
i think all of them look good but which
one is your favorite to start things off
well min lay i'm just gonna say that
name a couple of times anybody who's
even logged into chess.com should see
wonderful time at the very top of the
rankings he was known by many as the
strongest i am in the world until he got
his last grandmaster norm recently in
philadelphia he's now a grandmaster
elect but he has his work cut out for
him dingley wren he needs absolutely no
introduction but do not sleep on men his
opening repertoire is solid his style
caters incredibly well to rapid so i am
watching min and seeing if he can score
any big upsets and catch some big fish
in the cgc
levy what you got for us here
uh look i i see vladimir kramnik i'm
very interested to see what's going to
happen right of course he had this match
against uh vincent kymer which
ultimately led to him describing the
moral degradation of being flagged uh in
a completely winning endgame that
obviously would result in a punch to the
face very swiftly if it was done over
the board i'm curious to see how he does
not just against frank melcomian if i
can just pick him as the most
interesting matchup of the entire group
but obviously he's got to start
somewhere and that's against mr yeah in
the first round
uh good picks guys i also cannot wait i
think i like that matchup with dingley
ren and tuan midly as well the other
person who will be challenging for the
world chess championship throne in
dingley ren uh being of course yonda
pandashi uh but i'm gonna go back to you
danya and say regardless of the first
round matchups who do you got ultimately
emerging from group g listen my heart is
hoping that kromnic goes far and dingley
run goes far but the first time nihal
sarin turned heads was a couple of years
ago in the sec when he beat the likes of
alexander grishock the guy is an
absolute monster in time pressure
nihal saaren is one of my favorite
players to watch he's so versatile he's
wise beyond his years on and off the
chessboard and i think he's going to go
very very far i think this is going to
be one of his breakout tournaments he
may be below 2700 but uh if you just
watch his tournament performances you
could easily confuse him for a top 10
grand master i'm going with me hall
levy who do you see coming out of group
g and making their way to toronto
well if danya's math is correct that
means that when we reach that final
matchup it's going to be nihal sirin vs
dingley ren and if you're telling me
that nihal sirin is going to pull the
upset off then he should just win the
entire thing and we should all just go
home right now because if he's that good
he's that damn good but guys dingley
wren i just talked about this uh uh well
one of the other players in the event
obviously yanya pomnichi he's one of the
top three players in the world dingley
ren is in that group dingley ren is
winning this group guys i see dingley
wren i see nihal sauron i see nihal
saran maybe no longer afraid of spiders
as he told us in a junior's beaches
championship a few years ago but i see
another man in this in this group coming
out and that is andre esapenko i think
you guys turned your heads too fast on
that one i think he beats dingley red in
the second round and ultimately punches
his ticket to toronto canada wonder what
the fans think but there you have our
take on group g all right boys it's time
to dive into the final bracket that
bracket is group h and like all the
others it is an exciting one you have
aronian and maxine vashey legrove
pivoted against each other on opposite
sides will they be the final matchup in
this bracket uh so much to discuss here
so let's start off with the first
match-up and that is levon aronian
versus nicolas theodoro then we have
francisco vallejo ponz versus maxine
matlikov
then the frenchman with three names
maxine vashey lagrave takes on eduardo
iturizaga and finally samuel cevion the
american taking on rasmus spain levy i'm
letting you go first on this one what
you got for us
folks i'm going to break a truth bomb
for all of you uh nicolas theodoro is
the most underappreciated and
underestimated player in this entire
event that is kriyari this man was a
international master playing on
chess.com beating hikaru he he just beat
levon aronian in the olympia folks can
we just please get a reminder of that
that is by far the most interesting
first round matchup can he pull off the
shocking rapid upset and assert total
dominance over aronian or will will
aronians strike back all right well
that was good daniel what do you got
i literally i think levy reached into my
brain and pulled out all the words i was
going to say but the other matchup that
i'm so excited about is sam savion
against rasmus spain both of these
players they're dynamic they are young
samuel 7 recently broke into the
2700 club
and he's been winning the rcc weekend in
and weekend out so
i'm going to be watching these two young
talents battle it out very intently
maxine vashi lagrav versus eturi zaga is
a matchup i feel like we've seen in the
pro chess league over the years i can't
wait to see what happens there and
francisco vallejo ponz hasn't played in
a lot of online events how does he fare
against a regular online player in
matlakov we'll find out but okay if we
look at this bracket trying to pick a
winner who will be joining us in toronto
canada guys uh levy what do you got
look if i have to choose a match-up in
the finals i i think it's levon versus
mvl can we all agree on that but those
guys can beat each other on any
different day you run a simulation of
100 matchups it's 50 50. it's 49.51 i
don't know flip a coin my coin flip
landed it's mvl who's moving on to the
finals hey daniel who do you guys
interesting i also flipped a coin and my
coin landed on levon orronian and i
think the reason my coin was weighted in
lavon's favor is just because of
experience mvl he hasn't been playing
all that much in the last couple of
years we know that online chess success
is at least somewhat correlated with
experience and levon has been incredibly
active in the last couple of months i'm
going to have to go with lavon over
maxime
i i'd love to flip a coin but i used
them all to phone a friend already to
get some advice on this and i didn't get
any good advice i i i can't pick against
mvl or levon aronian but i think mbl has
to get by ituri zaga first and i think
that guy is so underrated and rapid and
blitz people should watch out for that
guy to maybe shock the world and punch
his ticket to toronto and okay that was
our look at the final bracket of the
first round of 64. it was group h wonder
what the fans think let us know and that
was our take on the final bracket
the big question is who will become the
first ever chess.com global champion
well donya i'm going to go back to you
and let you go first tell us when all
eight of them are in toronto who
ultimately emerges with the crown listen
danny one of my biggest regrets about
the last candidates tournament was that
wesley so was not participating in terms
of consistency if you put together if
you add up everything opening
preparation consistency nerves uh
ability to perform in clutch moments i'm
gonna have to go with wesley so i mean
the guy is an absolute tank he's going
to you know he's going to take this
tournament so seriously and that means
more opening ideas more exciting opening
preparation and cool calm and collected
wesley in critical moments my pick as
difficult as it is is gonna be wesley so
great pick there with wesley so levy
what do you have for us
look uh i said this once i hyped him up
already i'm going to hype him up to to
an extreme now the second best chess
player in the world right now is named
jan nipomnishi and it is unquestionable
that he is extremely good in classical
and blitz but he also just won
chess.com's rapid championship and i
think he is going to emerge out of
toronto as the winner of this event uh
you know both those picks obviously
amazing but
for lack of being accused of uh of bias
i guess i have to go with the guy hikaru
nakamura it's not just that he's the
most popular chess streamer on the
planet he continues to prove people
wrong that he did not retire his
performance in madrid to get to madrid
and all the things that he continues to
do to impress the world this is a format
that was created to be to be won by
hikaru nakamura it's rapid and
ultimately there will be blitz
tiebreakers and close matchups i think
it's really hard not to see hikaru
coming out of canada as the first ever
chefs.com global champion but there you
have it everybody those were our picks
you can let us know your picks leave
comments on twitter a comment on youtube
wherever wherever you might be watching
this video
from leave us a comment let us know your
pick and then make sure you take some
time to fill out a bracket not just
because there are thousands of dollars
in prizes for winning but if you somehow
fill out a perfect bracket you have a
chance to take away a 100 000
cash prize you can watch the entire
chess.com global championship the round
of 64 kicks off on september 14th and
you can tune in to wherever you prefer
watching chess from twitch.tv slash
chess youtube.com chess many of the
other platforms in which we stream too
the finals will be live starting
november 2nd and that everyone was our
chess.com global championship breakdown
thank you to levy thank you to donya and
thank you to all the fans who will take
the time to watch the event as we bring
it to you live and we will maybe see you
in toronto